David Milch my old friend from Yale has
been called televisions first artistic
genius and one of the people who have
who has called him that is me his his
powerful dramas and often disturbing
bizarre dramas that he conceives have
troubled the censors in the network's
for more than 25 years and also in
Congress and these dramas have explored
human weakness and violence in
disturbing and I believe very artful
ways he's one of televisions most
honored writers has won all kinds of
prizes for particular episodes of
individual shows and his most
significant credits are Hill Street
Blues for which he wanted wrote F
assad's that want a number of prizes
NYPD Blue which he co-created with
Steven Bochco
and most of all in some respects and
there's a kind of progression here that
we may get a chance to talk about today
the show that's running on HBO now the
pioneering Western one of the great
westerns I think in American cultural
history a show called Deadwood and I my
hope is an expectation is that many of
many of you without even realizing it
because people don't remember the names
of television writers or or creators
that much that many of you have probably
seen episodes of television programs
that David Milch as has written as I
mentioned David is an old comrade of
mine we met when David was a just I just
was a really a graduate student level at
Yale when I was beginning my career as a
professor and we had various kinds of
contact including a including a meeting
with David in which he heard that I had
been interested in in media and he
showed me a kind of film that he a short
film that he made in in a truck stop in
West Haven right near the right near
right near the exit for Yale University
that was full of the same bizarre humor
and and and black creativity that's
characteristic of his work even to this
day well I came to Hill Street after it
had been on for a couple of years and
there was so much about its approach the
multiple store
lines and that to which I gravitated but
III didn't feel I felt that it was a bit
of a sanitized version of of what police
work was having been incarcerated myself
on a number of occasions always through
false accusations and so when I came on
the first character that I introduced
was a character named Sal Benedetto who
was a bad cop who was always beaten up
Charlie hate and so on and who seemed to
me to be a more accurate representation
of at least one aspect of policing and
he wound up Benedetta wound up robbing a
bank and they sent a robot in he was
hiding in a vault and they sent a robot
in so they can watch what he's doing and
he starts beating the robot with his
fists and you know he's a kind of Unruh
constraint
you know he hates technology hates hates
all of it anyway in those days you
couldn't have such a cop as a regular
and they made me kill him but then
several years later I was put in charge
of the show and so I brought the
character back as Bunce this guy and
then we did a spin-off where they he was
a private detective and then when I did
NYPD Blue I asked Dennis if he would
play a similar character named Sipowicz
who was supposed to die at the end of
the first episode and he agreed
stipulating that he wanted to be killed
because it was the 170 third copy it
played so once we had him under contract
I admitted I had fibbed and he stayed
with the show twelve years I left after
the seventh seasons but Sipowicz is
actually and now you won't it's hard to
believe this but you know I think so
much of our creative process is on
conscious and my father's mother's name
was SAP which and it never occurred to
me till a number of years into NYPD Blue
that there might be any connection
between those things but he's he is a
character who had a lot of traits that
my dad had and and I think that one of
the opportunities of my life has been
the chance to discover love for
complicated personalities such as that
and so he's a guy that I have a lot of
affection for one way to think about
Sipowicz his character is to see him as
a as a as a character that you never
finished with David yeah one could argue
that there's a connection between
Sipowicz and Swearengen in Deadwood I
have some clips from Deadwood that we'll
show in a little while that will clarify
swear Injuns complex human humane
monstrosity David seems to have a gift
for creating monster characters who have
monstrous character so have human
qualities that you identify with and I'm
wondering whether you are aware either
of how horrible they seem but also of
how human they seem when you're actually
working on it yeah well you know my old
man used to beat me pretty good and and
I adored him and he wound up taking his
life and so you know and in fact you
know a colleague of ours about whom you
were speaking earlier RWB Lewis this is
to show you how complicated my old man
was Marv WB Lewis is a very
distinguished Yale professor who
published a number of important books
one of which one of which is a biography
of Edith Wharton did it wouldn't appeal
it sir
yeah it won the Pulitzer Prize the truth
of the matter is I said I wasn't gonna
say this in public but I will most of
that book a good part of that book was
written by David Milch
and David is acknowledged incredibly
generously in the beginning of that of
that book but not generously enough and
rwb Lewis admitted this to me because I
was his junior colleague David was a
sort of inspired graduate student who
was treated by the Yale faculty as some
as some fair-haired boy I mean I'm sure
I'm sure that many members of the Yale
faculty would be very disappointed to
see that David became a famous writer of
television programs instead of a
professor anyways we were doing a dick
and I are WB Lewis and I had a project
called the James family about Henry and
William James and so on and we were down
at the national endowment getting dough
I was writing the scripts and he was
writing the book and while we're down
there
dick was called out of the room while we
were pitching and we finished and
afterwards we went out and we had some
coffee and I said well I think it went
pretty well but bye-bye we're talking
for about ten minutes and he said listen
when I was called out of the room they
were telling me that your father had
died and had taken his life and his and
his instructions were that you were not
to be told until after the pitch was
finished the just to go into a to be
absolutely inappropriate and in
describing the kind of torment that some
souls are exposed to my dad was the only
child of the eldest of ten children
and her name as I say was SAP which her
last name and several of his uncles were
in fact contemporaries of his and one of
them was even younger than he was they
were all in the rackets but because he
was of the next generation he had to go
to college and he
came very prominent surgeon and a
professor of surgery as did my brother
my aunt my older brother but he was
always drawn to he was very frustrated
by his professional identity and we
would in in August every year he would
take us up to Saratoga to the racetrack
where all of his family would congregate
and I remember you might be old enough
to remember this there was a the
Kefauver hearings which are dramatized
and the Godfather were there tests where
the Congress is doing an investigation
and the mob and I remember the real
Kefauver hearings I would come home
every day there must there must have
been twenty five wise guys living in our
house for over a year because my dad
would do hernia operations on him so
they wouldn't have to go and testify you
know before the Kefauver committee so
it's very complicated sort of
relationship between learning he was a
very well recognized surgeon and so on
and and this other darker part of his
personality and his his identity as a
physician was the sort of civilizing
aspect of this he you know he would you
know my dad was a narcotic addict he was
an alcoholic he was all the stuff that I
became anyways towards the end of his
life my brother who had also become a
surgeon and sort of idolized my dad the
same way I did took over my father's
care and my dad would engage in
self-mutilation and all sorts of
unpleasant things and in his tormented
mind because his sense of self was so
associated with his professional
identity as a physician he became
convinced that since my brother had
become the caregiver in the
my brother was having sexual relations
with my mother and took his life in
front of them to punish them for that
worse than dead wood and and then his
last words were don't tell David until
he's done Oh with with his with his
pitch so the now I tell you that let me
hurry to say that I am a very happy and
grateful person and I was saying in a
class a little while ago that the future
is a great is constantly in the process
of interpreting the meaning of the past
I'll give you a quick example of that my
brother who was a surgeon in the
aftermath of my dad's passing retrained
himself as a hospice physician to care
for the terminally ill and has
established hospice programs in Romania
in Poland and Hungary runs a hospice in
Buffalo New York where we're from and I
choose to believe that my father in in
many ways was instrumental Mazzone
inability to accept himself in teaching
my brother that there was another way to
be a physician I think that the
fundamental responsibility of a medical
practitioner is not curative its
pastoral I will walk with you into
whatever darkness may come so I also
believe that my experience I didn't
volunteer this information professor
Thorburn asked me a question and so and
I try to answer it honestly that the the
I'll tell you one more story from me
okay very quickly when I started to
write out there I want a lot of prizes
and one of which is a Humanitas prize
which is given by the Catholic Church
for the most uplifting whatever it is
fifteen grand tax-free and I kept
winning this thing and I and at that
point I was a heroin addict very bitter
by Papa so I would make it my business
whenever I would come back to get the
next award to tell the priest father I
can't remember his name
anyways I said I I'm sure will please
you to know that I took that money and
bought a racehorse with it which is what
the church probably would have wanted me
to do trying to scandalize him and he
would and I hated this guy I just hated
him and I could never figure out why I
hated him so much and I said he said
this buckteeth than his stupid anyway so
it was like he knew something but he
would look at you and he smiles like he
knew something about you you didn't know
about yourself
I hate people like there so anyways
years go by and I won a few more times
and finally I got sober and I had the
opportunity finally when I won this
award again I said you know I've never
liked whatever this guy's name his
father so on so I I don't like the way
he looks I don't like his buck teeth he
was sitting right next to me and I said
and this thing I really didn't like is
that he always had to smile when I would
try to offend them like he knew
something about me I didn't know about
myself I said I thank God that I have
lived long enough to have come to
understand that the shadow in which I
felt that all of my characters had to
move and live in fact
was cast by God's sheltering hand and
that's what the father knew about me
that I didn't know about myself so
that's all I say about there it's I I
hate to I hate to turn to sort of a less
sombre themes but I'm one way to do this
I think maybe to pick up on what David
was saying about doc about doctors as he
was talking I had two reactions one was
I heard Dennis friends and I mean I'm
absolutely amazed by the closeness with
which the dialogue that Dennis Franz
speaks in at least three different shows
sounds like David Milch is ordinary talk
and it tells you something about how
close he actually is to that character
and something of what he said also I
think about the the some of the terrible
aspects of his own autobiography have
clearly that material has clearly seeped
into his work in very interesting ways
the the obscenity in Deadwood is as I
mentioned that I was interested in
trying to identify what principles of
organization operate in a society in
which law does not exist and because
Deadwood was a criminal community it was
a it was on land which had just been
ceded to the Indians and they didn't
want to pass any laws because if they
passed laws that would mean that their
claims could be overturned so they were
just trying to steal everything without
having any laws at all it was sort of a
laboratory environment in which one then
tries to identify what principles of
governance develop language it seemed to
me had to serve two functions the first
was to beat down the viewers
pre-existing expectation that any law
would be obeyed that is every sentence
is so soaked with obscenity as to bleach
out the expectation that any civility
can be
expected to govern in any scene
therefore how do you live in such an
emotional environment as a viewer so
that so that was the first part of it
then I wanted to show how words
generated meaning not because of any
intrinsic quality but because of the
context of emotional Association in
which they were expressed swear engines
the reason that I took a moment to
express my thanks to Professor Thorburn
is that in the in his choice of scenes
he demonstrated a of emotional
connection to the materials which helped
me to understand my own intentions
that's how in a conversation in which
let's say professor Thorburn is
Swearengen and I'm Wu one word given
enough emotional communication can bear
the weight of an entire exchange of a
whole story can be told with one word if
the emotions in the context are
adequately rendered and then the in the
development of the relationship between
Swearengen and Wu what I wanted to show
was despite all of the prejudices that
existed about Asians and by extension
other minorities how a kind of order
could generate itself which was if not
humane at least humanizing as a contrary
impulse we're gonna turn to questions
from the audience in a second so
formulate your questions and we're going
to let me remind you that we are audio
taping and videotaping this so identify
yourself unless you want to remain
anonymous when you come to these
microphones begin to formulate your
questions I'll start but I hope people
will start coming to the mics one
question David that well I have to a
question and a half the half question is
to make you continue a little bit more
on the on the question of the profanity
in the show
I remember reading something maybe it
was in mark singers piece in The New
Yorker about you but maybe it was
elsewhere but in some piece I read about
your dealings with HBO I recall you're
actually having been asked by HBO to
justify the dirty language yeah and did
you write a paper or some sort of report
well the HBO was worried about yeah what
in fact the the guardians of the Western
of the classical movie westerns we're
very much offended by the obscenity in
Deadwood and asked me to make the case
to prove that there had been such
obscenity as opposed to the language
which obtained and the westerns of the
30s 40s and 50s and a couple of things
to say about that the language which
obtained in those westerns had nothing
to do with the way people spoke in the
West in the 1870s and everything to do
with the exigencies of the Jewish
immigrants who ran Hollywood who wanted
to send a message that they weren't
going to rock the boat in terms of the
stories that they were telling and there
had been a period of five or ten years
in the late teens and early 20s where
films had gotten a little racy and what
the gold winds and the Lasky's and the
Louie B Mayer's and you can finish the
xanax got together and hired a front
Gentile named Hayes who instituted what
was called the Hayes production code
which proclaimed that obscenity in word
thought or deed was an offense not only
against the laws of man but against
divine law and would not be tolerated in
their films which was a way of saying we
ain't gonna rock the boat now if you
an artist when you're confronted with
those kind of strictures you can refuse
to participate or you can try and find a
way to internalize those strictures such
that it does not distort the story
you're trying to tell and the great
storytellers in films of the 30s and 40s
extrapolated a character who was very
laconic not only didn't use swear words
he just didn't talk much at all and
whose stoicism invoked a set of values
which now when we see a great work of
art we bind to that work of art having
to do with if we're children when we see
it that's a fundamental imaginative
reality which we are not going to see
changed so instead of saying I like
shame what we say is that's not the way
they talked in 1870
that ain't my problem but it became my
problem because there was hbo's problem
and so I did the research the the best
secondary witnesses Menken in the book
called the American language and I'm
sure you know Dan Boorstin you knew Dan
Austin who wrote about what it was that
when the westering impulse to the extent
that it was a refute it was that you
know if you went out to an environment
like this it wasn't because you were
doing great in wilkes-barre Pennsylvania
you know there was there were some
personality attributes usually maybe
there was a warrant or two out for you
and the other thing to remember is these
weren't farming communities mining what
the mining law said that you owned a
claim only as long as you were on it and
working it and if you've left for three
days whoever came
could take it from so you had to be
willing to resort to violence and in the
same way that apes so that they don't
have to be fighting all the time develop
you know this kind of stuff obscenity
was used as a way of announcing don't
come in here with any weak stuff you
know if you're gonna and the rest of it
was because there were no laws at all
any question was potentially a lethal
had lethal implications if I say to you
where you from you're usually gonna say
you know I'm from wherever I'm from in
Deadwood if you say where you're from
the guy says what the [ __ ] is that to
you be so that immediately it becomes a
potentially mortal situation because he
doesn't know if you're out there with a
warrant for his arrest or so that
combination it seemed to me all all of
which worked to create the kind of
extremity of language and and what I
wanted to do as I say after bleeding
after establishing that premise to then
show how language came to complicate
itself as one of the alternatives to
statute in terms of how people govern
their behavior now you see rich rich and
remarkable as that isn't compelling in a
way as that is there's still a lot about
the language of Deadwood you haven't
discussed David I want to ask you about
an another aster
I've often thought that one of the
things that doubles the profanity is the
almost Shakespearean grandiloquence of
some of the characters I'm thinking
especially of that sleazy mayor yeah who
goes around sometimes he actually
delivers soliloquies doesn't it yeah and
and also the level of his language is
virtue as they sound
he sounds often like a kind of Victorian
preacher and his vocabulary is immensely
large I'm wondering about now it's
obvious that you are aware of the this
distinction what what effects do you
hope is cream well one thing to remember
is this was Victorian times
and to the extent that people had booked
learning the book learning they had had
to do with Victorian literature in the
Bible and Shakespeare you know there's a
wonderful story about Kit Carson riding
seven days to get his new collection of
Sir Walter Scott and so it seemed to me
in in that regard that those people who
and and and it wasn't so much that they
had been a school that they were
autodidact
they were self-taught and the reason and
and and people in that environment who
had recourse to books were highly highly
motivated it was an alternative state of
being for them which which stood in
contrast to the way they were living
their lives so it seemed to me to be
credible at that level that people who
had recourse to that sort of rhetoric
you know went for the gusto in terms of
the what professor Thorburn talks about
is the grandiloquence of some of their
speech but it seemed to me also that as
a work generates its own reality in the
same way that was language that wu's
single english word in english that he
he knows came to because of the
complication of the emotional
transaction became enriched in the
viewers understanding by tonality z' and
rhythms that I feel that the metrics of
speech are important and representative
even in those of us who feel mistakenly
as I believe that we are separate from
each other as individuals it seems to me
that the way God says I to have a hand
here is in the rhythms and metrics of
speech so that even unbeknownst to
themselves they honor a divine presence
in certain of the locutions of Deadwood
i I don't want you to feel anxiety
because I have plenty of things to ask
David about so if you're happy with this
don't worry about it but if you do have
questions please sir come up to the
microphone please come forward sir I I
feel like Benny Hinn right there
okay I'm not DeWitt Henry from Emerson
College and my question to think what
that means well
Richard Yates is one oh really oh sure
sure I know yes of course I guess it's a
writer's question given the scope of a
series like Deadwood at least to an
outsider it has the intensity of a
Victorian novel and I'm wondering
exactly how you are the auteur how you
manage to subcontract various episodes
to outside writers how you initiate them
do you give them treatments are there
storyboards that they're filling in or
can they really take an improvisational
role in directing the direction of the
story you know I believe that all
storytelling is collaborative and one
way or another and and nobody writes an
episode independently or goes off and
writes an episode we all all the writers
are in a room all the time
in one room and so that's so so every
scene is generated in that one horrible
stinking trailer which is just 50 yards
from the set and you know once the scene
is generated we don't we don't let it
ripen particularly it you know usually
the scene is written either the day that
it's shot or the day before it's shot
and there are no scripts you know
there's no finished script before the
shooting begins we you know if if the
shoot is an average of 12 days the
script is finished on the 12th day of
the shoot
and so that's the idea of an out being
an out or you know I don't believe in
any of that [ __ ] of any of that stuff
anyway you know I don't I don't care
whose name is yeah you're not on the set
now what's your angle
yes forgive me but but you know that I
just don't care about that if this gives
us an excuse to able to talk a little
bit about something I'd mentioned to you
I wanted to ask you about and again I
think I'm cribbing here from there was a
brilliant maybe overly loving portrait
of David in The New Yorker recently by a
guy who was a Yale friend of his and I
don't never met that guy but the guy had
sat at David's feet it yeah I mean David
didn't remember him that's all that was
well I was loading no David taught David
taught courses there but in fact in the
piece he talks about how intimidating
even though David was only a few years
older than he and he was like an
undergraduate how intimidating David was
to the other undergraduate it's a
wonderful piece on the guy who wrote it
is a wonderful writers name is mark
singer and he's a it's a it's a very
good piece of writing in its own way and
it gets equally into aspects of David's
vision of life and and and it's
certainly worth reading one of the
things that he says in that in the in
that piece he describes David's methods
of writing and they are astonishing and
in many ways very strange maybe you
could tell our audience about how you
write an episode of Deadwood what how
you settle in front of them yeah well I
tried III I don't think about writing
when I'm not writing and I won't plan a
scene before I write it and that has to
do with I would hasten to add that you
know the chemist kekulé a I think I tell
the story in that piece about you know
the guy who figured out the structure of
the benzene ring and he'd worked on it
for 20 years and then he had a dream he
saw
snake swallowing its tail he said that's
it that's the structure of benzene ring
so the next day they said to him you
know not bad you go to sleep you wake up
you got the patent on the benzene ring
he said visions come to prepared spirits
and so that what I what I would propose
is you know I spent years and years and
years I remember I spent one useful
period of 15 months writing the same 12
pages word for word
every morning word for word because you
know my wiring is a little iffy and so
having now come to a point in in in my
life where I feel that at one level you
know I was getting ready to be able to
work this way through all the period of
time when I worked a different way but
now I don't I don't plan the episodes I
don't plan the scenes and and and yet I
feel that these characters are I've
you've heard me say a few times probably
until some of you want to gouge your
eyes out like their grapes that that I
believe that our sense of ourselves as
separate from each other is an illusion
and in fact that we are organs of some
larger organism which knows us although
we do not know it and if that is the
case I regard myself as a vessel of
whatever that larger organism is rather
or its instrument rather than as the
source of the scenes so a lot of what I
do is try to get out of the way and
that's the way I work on my writing
that's where I work with the actors
that's the way I edit and and I find
that it puts me in the path of an
enormous amount of energy as I say you
know 15
for 12 pages is what some might define
as a meager output but I do you know
I've done 350 hours of episodes over the
past decade or so and and and more
recently you know this is this is hi
this is work which is as good as I can
do no matter how long I spent on it and
and I think that has to do to some
extent with a readying of the Spirit in
humility to receive rather than to
regard myself as the the as generating
it some of the details are interesting
David I mean in The New Yorker piece
singer describes how you will go down
and and sit in front of a monitor and
someone is typing it and you don't write
you don't actually do the right no
because you do it through talking I'm an
obsessive-compulsive so if I have if I
can put my hands on anything we're all
in trouble so you know I had no phone I
have no watch I don't know how to use a
computer because if I mean if I even use
a pencil you know come back and see me
in three months I'll be hanging upside
down in gravity boots you know because
because I think that when you're you
know the the brain is very plastic which
is to say very malleable when you're
very young and I think if it gets shaken
in certain ways you're predisposed to
certain neural in capacities and you
fall into repetitive patterns of
behaviors called repetition compulsion
it's called a lot of things anyways
I find that I function most effectively
when I sort of disembody myself so I
just lie there and and and I talk and
the words come up on the screen and then
I fixed the words but I never actually
lay my hands on anything and and it's
certainly help to diminish my
pharmacological obligations listening to
David for a while I realized that he has
a kind of repertoire of ways of
describing these former Columbia out of
my mind that are that are witty but also
unsettling and something of the way the
the show is another question that I've
always had about Deadwood annette has
become much more intense and as I've
watched recent episodes David is the
timeframe sometimes it seems as if a
second episode begins one minute after
the other is that true of it do you
think of it as every episode like no but
but some episodes but if it happens that
way that's the way it happens you know
sometimes a day will go by I originally
intended that each season would be one
year in the life of the camp the camp
was destroyed at the end of four years
and but but I do title at the materials
the one thing I knew for example at the
end of this season that we just finished
shooting last week was it culminated
with the elections and there these are
90% of these are true stories and a
Bullock was defeated in the election
because George Hearst the father William
Randolph Hearst fixed the election and
and Bullock was so pissed off he
barricaded himself in the office and
wouldn't leave wouldn't turn over the
badge to the idiot who would this is the
at the yeah this is either unaired
episodes and so the one thing I knew at
the end of the third season which we
just finished shooting which will go on
in June was that was the concluding
sequence never got to it you know the
season was over I never got to that
speed and which caused a few raised
eyebrows and all the ad campaigns and
everything which were based on that
culminating sequence because I had sold
it seemed to me that the great moment in
American history was after we'd won the
Revolutionary War
where everyone wanted to make Washington
the king and the Continental Congress
was a bunch of slugs and corrupt you
know hacks and Washington went and knelt
and presented his sword to the
Continental Congress saying that it
would be a government of laws and not a
men and Swearengen went and persuaded
Bullock even though it had been a
corrupt election to go ahead and
acknowledge the defeat so that so that
the the loyalty would no longer be to
Bullock but to the democratic process
and I really wanted to finish this
season with that story and but you know
we just we just didn't get there so
we're gonna open next season with that
story and when you say you didn't get
the data does that mean because as as
the actual act of writing scene-by-scene
occurred you fat you you made greater
discoveries and I mean you have you know
each scene exists in terms of its
internal dynamics and then it exists in
connection with each scene is is is
becomes as if it were a character in
conversation with another character
which is the other scene which pre
precedes it and so on and your first
loyalty has to be to the thing which
already lives you know what Swearengen
says if you want to hear God laugh tell
him your plans you know my plan was to
have Bullock and you know but that isn't
where the characters were going so I you
know Bullock wound up Bullock led the
inauguration parade for Teddy Roosevelt
Bullock was wound up Teddy Roosevelt's
best friend
see he's talking about the historical
Bullock I picked up on that the
historical said not the kid not the
character and and and and and but but
this election was a real election that
the real George Hearst fixed and to the
extent that Teddy Roosevelt was the
first political figure who reigned in
the pure capital
the robber barons it seemed to me
crucial to render the dynamic between
Bullock and George Hearst who and so
that's the part that took longer and so
that there went the election first I
just want to say I don't know if it
sounds pretentious but thank you so much
for Deadwood it's unbelievable so I have
a chance to ask you question my head is
swarming so I'm gonna put aside the the
desire to be self-seeking and ask you
about the PAP I've heard you helped out
piays yeah you know who myself being a
writer and a spine filmmaker and
recovering addict so I'm gonna put aside
better so that Denver happened you just
put it aside off the table I'm wondering
I guess the first question that was
addressed the storytelling I'm wondering
how you the the the are you essentially
the director if you could explain that
the process of directing that with the
actors and because there's some of the
most phenomenal performances I've ever
seen it particularly if the guy you know
Swearengen the actor's name yeah Shane
yeah and I'm I'm just wondering if you
explain how you know you know who I had
written that part for Eddie O'Neill from
married with children and they wouldn't
cast them because it ain't television
it's HBO well and then I then we cast
powers boosts and powers got sick and I
told him if he got well I'd write a
different part for him but we had to go
ahead and shoot and so then we came to
Ian and I'd say Ian is wonderful but
anyway the way that again titles don't
really mean too much to me mine or
anybody else's and so we all you know
after a scenes been written I come down
on a set and we walked through it and
and I had my say and
the director has his say and so on and
the actors do and I don't mean to
suggest it's a democracy it isn't but I
try to answer to a higher kind of
principle which is to be respectful and
of you know what other people are
feeling or other peoples in capacities
you know sometimes an actor doesn't do
well with a particular kind of scene and
I'll change the scene on the spot or
I'll see something and that's that's one
of the upsides of working the way we do
is that everybody's prepared to change
anything you know all the way even in
editing you know take a scene now take
the end of the scene and put it at the
beginning of the scene you know know
well Walter Hill was the first director
and Walter has done a lot of films and
as he said we parted very amiably but he
said there's only room for one king of
the castle and I don't think of myself
that way but he he did he thought of
himself that way and but you know I
thought he did a wonderful job but David
it is true that your and gate
involvement with dead was much more
intense than typical writers were oh
yeah and hpa2 the actors all the time
HBO insists on that because it's because
there's no script so you know they say
well you know the script you better be
well that's true you know you better be
down there because the actors have no
chance to prepare the scene you know the
director has no chance to visualize the
scene so you know there you go Kevin my
name is Kevin regal I'm in professor
Thorpe ins television class hi Kevin um
okay you talked earlier about some of
the decisions
this was actually in class I guess about
some of the decisions that went into
deciding into the genesis of Deadwood
but I'm curious why you decided to set
it in the American West I mean there
aren't any other westerns on television
today and it they've haven't had a
particularly strong go of it the movies
recently I'm wondering what drew you to
that yeah well I would say a couple of
things about that
that's a nasty piece of gum on the
bottom of my shoe but I'm very proud
that I got my shoe shine in LaGuardia
Airport the all that's you know at the
racetrack where I have been occasionally
abducted and forced to spend large
amounts of time there's an expression
about the smart money and that the smart
money easily misses its bus in the
morning and the application of that is
that you know in terms of what kind of
series is involved at a given time
that's nonsense
you know what when a given form say the
Western is completely out of vogue what
that means is that the it's the
opportunity exists for a revisiting from
a different point of view so I never
were you know the one thing everybody
knew when NYPD Blue went on the air was
the attention span of the audience had
been infantilized by MTV everybody hated
cops you know
no shot so I don't worry about that but
the the other thing is that that I was
interested in particular in Deadwood
because it was a criminal enterprise it
acknowledged itself as a criminal
enterprise
when Wild Bill Hickok was killed they
acquitted the guy because they didn't
want to be
taken for having recognized any kind of
law because if they recognize one kind
of law then what someone would have had
the right to say is you just stole all
this from the Indians
my name is Sachin I'm postdoc and my
question was you were talking about the
rehearsal process and I was curious
about over the course of NYPD Blue
Deadwood I guess germinates in your head
and/or this Roman version of it yeah so
what I'm sort of really curious to know
is as you kind of revisit the character
sort of on a weekly episode episode
basis does Swearengen really emanate in
origins from from CIPA wicks if he does
I mean he's a darker version so I guess
in your heart did you kind of leave NYPD
Blue at some point and when did that
maybe happen and when did all of a
sudden you find yourself thinking more
and more about Deadwood and less and
less about yes I'm not a good witness
about that stuff about my own you know
biography in it in that regard was
creative the big thing for me was I was
loaded when I was doing NYPD Blue and I
got sober and so and I think that
accounts for a lot of the changes and
the the Swearengen is was a real guy how
about this Swearengen was a twin how'd
you like to meet his twin and so it's
it's a I think that there's a kind of
flux
you know there's my own experience but
there's also you know everything that I
read and I read all the time every day
you know and and and characters will
come alive in my mind
and you know and then they they exist
independently and then experiences of
mine or past characters I've worked on
might get drawn into their orbit and it
doesn't do to in some clay oh I guess I
was teaching this morning at Columbia we
didn't talk about Zeno's paradox in your
class did we you know the the idea that
Monnaie purely logical form you know the
hare never catches the tortoise if he
keeps catching it if he keeps closing it
by half and yet all of vine Stein's you
know theorems are based on that kind of
mathematical logic and which is to say
that I believe that subject and object
which is the basis of Zeno's paradox is
an illusion and that in fact what was
subject is is constantly becoming object
and go so to separate me as a discrete
entity and what was i working on and how
did it germinate and stuff is to fail to
recognize that I am a I'm just sort of a
way station for all kinds influences
that come in and out and thankfully
Vicodin has been eliminated in that it's
very helpful thank you sir yes good
evening my name is Robin comedy Ellen hi
I wanted to thank you for Sipowicz
you know welcome I wanted to thank you
also for Deadwood my heart's in Deadwood
we have a person in common out there
Mary Copco oh sure
very cop goes the deadwood librarian
who's been so helpful does she's
wonderful I had a bunch of questions but
I didn't like this gentleman over here
my head spinning as well because I don't
know which to pick first
let me ask you a question do you ever
get out to Los Angeles not yet
well you should come out and be an extra
on the show we'll make you a dancehall
girl
and because you know Mary was Mary came
out that would be my dream yes I and we
will and will and you can ask me all the
questions you want could I have my don't
you ask one question one now when one
question yeah okay I suppose we did
Walcott come from and if I may give you
an invitation I'm a future Deadwood
resident I have a mineral claim right
down the road from friendship monument
had a girl and if you have any other
backdrop with nothing in the way it
would be my honor
okay alright
Woollcott thank you so much
look at there
Wolcott was George Hearst geologist and
I wanted to present a kind of forerunner
or an avatar of George Hearst who
embodied the principles of capitalism
and to show that the rapacity and
veracity vor a of the capitalist process
had a sexual predicate and so I wanted
to have a serial killer who was also a
geologist as the precursor in the second
season to Hearst who would appear in the
third season and then it seemed to me
that the guy who had played the first
murderer the murder of one of the first
hero Wild Bill Hickok could also play
the geologists were yeah uh-huh
good for you in your mind it was
significant that the same actor played
this tool I just felt like he wasn't
wrong it was hard to recognize him at
first yeah does come as a shock if
you're watching yeah it it's an unusual
decision because usually it
you would think it violates the sort of
fictional or any of the word to have a
dead person come along yeah and you'll
recall however that I did that with
bunts you know it's Sal Sal Benedetto
and it seems to me that there that you
you can't be too careful ear about it
but there was something in the soul of
Jack McCall I think which survived his
decease and which reincarnated itself in
an impulse
you know George Hearst says I am the boy
the earth talks to he believed that the
earth spoke to him and that particular
kind of demonic kind of messianic
narcissism I think is often shared by
assassins and and the extremely wealthy
hi Paul I work actually in Cambridge
working for a newspaper that it's a
homeless newspaper where a lot of
homeless people can contribute writing
and a lot of times I encounter a lot of
a lot of writing by people who are
mentally divergent you know whatever you
want to call it yeah I don't like to
necessarily hear mental illness mental
and I saw that but my question for you
is through your years of you know
self-confessed madness and subsequent
drug abuse did you have any moments of
clarity where I don't know maybe even in
the midst of the drugs and and your
mind's going out of control
where all of a sudden you could sort of
see yourself clearly or anything like
that that really helped bring your
writing to I don't know I don't know
about the last part about it's helping
to bring my I remember once I turned out
to be burying myself in Mexico and that
got my attention I was I was working for
these criminals I suppose would be the
fair way to put it and we were
during stuff and and the the I had
gotten involved with them as these
things usually occur by steps and I'd
sold my passport to him about six months
before and told myself and that's as far
as I go so six months later I'm down in
Mexico doing the rest of this stuff and
there's there's a chemist down there
this lunatic chemist with he was like he
was from central casting you know are
these bottle glasses and there he'd get
in a car and he'd have an accident like
within 200 feet he would he would hit a
burro or something and start throwing
pesos everywhere so he contracted a bit
of a stomachache and he had a consort
named yum-yum who decided to treat his
tummy ache with an enema are you sure
this isn't well it was an episode
anyways as it turned out he had
peritonitis and she killed him with this
enema and we were all down there
illegally and so I'm out there digging
this guy's grave and in our finger there
outside Cuernavaca and tossed the body
and you know now I figure well let me
see if I can get some ID in case at some
point I try to do the right thing you
know contact as relatives let him know
the news of his finish because we were
all down there you know and it was me he
had my passport that I had sold six
months before that they had used you
know and only the most liberal
applications of chloroform kept that
moment of clarity from extending into a
protect protracted bout of lucidity and
perhaps a life change but that's why
they make chloroform and I was able to
keep going for a number
Aaron can't a mighty Roman playwright
you've clearly done a whole lot of
historical research for Deadwood and
there's a whole set of various truths
which some of them contradict how do you
reconcile that with the very different
truth that you're working with in the
world of Deadwood give me a give me a
for instance for instance you've talked
about several characters the doctor who
is a plausible construction from but he
didn't exist and yet he's interacting
with all necessary postulate yes I guess
what I was saying was that that there
were doctors out there but the and the
there were the civil war was really the
formative experience for any physician
during that period and so I the the I've
never consciously gone against what I
took to be an historical truth
in fact I there have been certain
historical truths which I decided had to
be [ __ ] and and so I tried to tell
the story of why I thought for example
when Wild Bill Hickok was killed
everyone says well you had the dead
man's hand you know aces over eights and
every time I would read that I would
think who the hell noticed what his hand
was if he just had his head blown off I
mean I would think you'd probably be
saying come on feets don't fail me now
you know and so in my subsequent
research there was a captain Massie who
toured who who kept in his wrist the
bullet fragment at the table and kept
the bullet fragment in his wrist so now
I'm thinking well so I'm captain Massie
I'm touring I need a little
embellishment you know besides here's
the bullet my wrist so I say and do you
know that the what the hand was that he
was holding and it just gives my story
so I did that story of how captain
Massey came to make up what has come to
be taken as an historical fact but I try
not to do the other thing which is
encountering some fact which I believe
to be true I try never to contradict
that but I do take the license of if we
don't know I try to expel Calamity Jane
I always nursed a suspicion didn't look
like Doris Day so you know I did my
research and I figured I mean I decided
that that was what she was like the way
she's portrayed so but forgive me if a
my encountering the question you're
trying to put her room that is the
question but if I'm remembering
correctly which I may not be in the
first episode you changed the dates of
when everybody arrived in the city and
sort of I'm curious about that may be
the only place you'd do something like
that but how you made this decision
I mean artistic that way yeah the best
documentation I could find had Hickok
arriving July 30th and Bullock arriving
August 2nd of 1876 and I figured you
know that was okay
the there there are those who argued
that Bullock never met Hickok
but his great-nephew name quell our I
think was a fellas name the great nephew
recounted an anecdote that Bullock told
about having encountered Hickok and
butBut I having said all of that you
know those kinds of minor
reconciliations or religions or so on I
I think so long as you know Melville
talked about the truth and the very
truth and I if I can stay with the what
I feel as the very truth I guess I do
allow myself that sort of latitude you
know 48 hours
carry this forward a little bit I think
that was a very interesting question
absolutely and requires you know in I
mean look it could be a thesis it's a
very important matter that the treatment
of history and westerns in general but
David you you may have not given a you
may have given the impression at least
two members of the audience who don't
know the show as well as some of the
rest of us that or don't know the
background that it that in fact there
are only a few connections to historical
fact but indeed but in fact most of this
is grounded in history I would say 90%
not just bullet but the death of the boy
is happen there was a man named
Swearengen that's yeah EB Farnum was the
first mayor and Merrick aw Merrick was
the first newspaper guy and Sol star was
the second mayor and served ten terms
and tricks even Trixie is recorded as
having existed and having put one
through the guy's head in a collection
called early pioneer days and the Black
Hills by a writer named aclinic in the
story that he tells the guy got up and
was walking around the following day and
that's one that I disagreed with but but
it's it's clients Brooks for whom both
professors Thorburn
and I have a real reverence and
gratitude in trying to educate me a
little bit about the different kinds of
truths suggested that the truths of
reportage or of history depend upon to
the extent they depend upon anything a
correspondence to an externally
verifiable reality and the truths of
storytelling are the truths of an
internal emotional coherence and that
can quickly become the refuge of a
charlatan but I guess I'd have to plead
guilty to that possibility
Clarence Brooks
former professor at Yale author of among
other great works anyone know the
well-wrought urn one of the great books
of formalist criticism and who found a
little something to admire and
professors Thorburn not to mention this
guy saying your work is really great I
think you said network it was hacks and
it works we were scared of a lot of
stuff I think you and Sam Bosco worked
great together and you put some stuff
together really hope TV sue it was
because when cable came around networks
were in trouble anyway so when you did
Deadwood it surprises them all with
stuff that is real and people who really
liked it to get Emmys and the network's
going on what this is about
because they can't get it through their
heads they're getting it because it's
real because it's honest and they don't
see that because it's so afraid of it
ness the licenses of viewers know
anything when you show people three
rounds and things like that to do to go
so far
yeah it really their rear end to see if
it's show to help them see that you know
people people want to see that for some
reason even Dennis's but I still it's
it's something real I think people
there's an audience out there for that
they don't like stupid no you know like
when Evan Spelling did the stuff he did
there's basically caught book material
but when you guys can Wong was different
he was supposed to be what it was and I
want to thank you for that cuz you
really helped TV on and save them from
cable I appreciate it thank you very
much where folks were in the what what
what my friend Henry Jenkins calls the
lightning round now we have eight
minutes so I want to ask our questioners
to be succinct and I want to ask David
to be succinct also do your best and I
shall try hi my name is Agee I'm not a
writer I'm an engineer so my question
will be somewhat general as I understand
it your work seems to focus on finding
the humanity and characters that are
somewhat morally ambiguous I should
always say and this can make for very
moving and interesting television but I
wonder if you think that there is any
downside to it or to put it another way
do you think some things and maybe even
some people are merely unforgivable
and if not can that be a dangerous
position to hold and I think I asked
this in part because of the current
political climate and yeah thank you
thank you are certain people
unforgivable no I don't think so
I think that that not even that serial
killer in the show no no and that was
sort of why I wanted to not even your
old fraternity friend the president not
even my old fraternity friend the
president especially not him whom I find
to be more of a genial boob than a moral
menace let me let me say and I forgive
me for not being brief but I do want to
say something to the writers did please
forgive me sir wait you asked your
question so why don't we let while I do
the last question so you take your time
those two okay no no finished okay then
I think that the war in Iraq has ever so
much more to do with the abdication with
the media's abdication of its moral
responsibility than with the
deficiencies of our president I think
that the media have infantilized the
expectations of the audience for the
lack because of the lack of a some sort
of transcendent informing vision I
believe that the surrogate existence
that is provided by television has come
to supplant the genuine emotional
of the populace I believe therefore that
the reason that I have chosen not to do
any more contemporary drama is because
the assault on the collective
sensibility of 911 was such as to make
the audience give the audience so much
fear that the only way that they could
be placated was with a television series
a miniseries which would be finished in
three weeks and which would tell them
that you do not have to fear danger here
because we are going to take the war
over there and the the rationale for
that war had nothing to do with weapons
of mass destruction and everything to do
with the habituation of the viewing
public to the shaping of human
experience in distorted forms for which
the media is responsible so that the
first three weeks of the Iraq miniseries
was received with the enormous public
approval because it was the series that
we wanted to see and it was the triumph
of American weaponry and it had a
beginning a middle and an end and the
disaffection with the Iraq war has
nothing to do with what is going on with
the Iraqi people and everything to do
with the fact that that series is over
we don't want to see that series anymore
we wanted to be narcotized in our
reaction to the assault on the World
Trade Center we got what we were looking
for don't be bothering us anymore with
the goddamn roadside bombs bring the
boys home well the boys were never
coming home after three weeks war isn't
like that it was a ward undertaken for
the wrong reasons and responded to
for reasons that the public has
absolutely no conception about and
therefore the dialogue that's going on
about President Bush has nothing to do
with President Bush and everything to do
with the fact that he is the failed
central character in an infantile drama
which was being staged to narcotized the
American public and no matter who was in
office the the so-called intelligentsia
would be trivializing him and
criticizing him now which is not to say
that he's not a [ __ ]
I know better than anyone else I spent a
lot of time with him you know we're
fraternity brothers but that is not
what's happening in society in America
today there is nothing war is a terrible
terrible terrible thing and if you want
to know who told the biggest lie in
order to get our country into war it
wasn't George Bush it was one of our
great presidents Franklin Delano
Roosevelt who knew that we were going to
be attacked at Pearl Harbor and sat on
the information because he knew what he
had to do to mobilize public opinion so
it's got a and and I'm not defending I'm
not criticizing Franklin Roosevelt I'm
not defending George Bush I am saying
that there's a different drama which is
enacting itself in our country right now
and it has to do with a failure to
acknowledge the necessary moral and
imaginative predicate in what has become
an entirely virtual existence which is
you know people spend more than half
their waking hours watching television
just think about that for a second they
spend more than half their waking hours
watching television that has to shape
the neural pathways it creates and
impatience for example with irresolution
the
and I'm doing what I can and to tell
stories which engage those issues in
ways that can engage the imagination so
people don't feel threatened by it
that's why I won't do it anymore
contemporary series because that image
is so indelibly imprinted on the
American consciousness that we are
prepared let me tell you for a genocide
all of this [ __ ] about Iraq let one
more plane go into one more big building
and the American public will sign on to
the extermination of every one of the
Muslim faith trust me I hope you're
wrong
oh I hope I'm wrong too but it'll happen
like that do you remember your question
that's all right go ahead go ahead
this we're shifting gears to conclude
this is our final question um I feel
like a schmuck and a half because what
I'm about to say is might come off as
mildly critical and and I this has also
been it's a bit intimidating to come up
here because there are not one but two
people that I greatly admire in this
let's better go hell of a thing divide
and conquer well consider but I wanted
to ask you about Hill Street Blues and
whatever like that show you been working
on and this is a question about women
I'm been watching my PD blue and
Deadwood downloaded Isis I'm sorry
lately we can't afford HBO at my house
and it is it's it's an it's an
extraordinary feeling to be in an
environment of eloquent masculinity of a
kind that I didn't really experience as
a kid and went by the time I got to
college I got sort of eloquent something
in the middle yeah from my from my
housemates of whatnot but I always
wonder where the it seems like someone
likes it wit someone even like John
Kelly certainly Swearengen these are
these whole consciousnesses but I wonder
where's the women basically or I mean
and the women are clearly there but none
of them ever have ever struck me as
being all the way there and I wonder if
you're it's partially a question of
writing this is hard as hell man this is
partially a question of the writing
process when you are sort of reaching
out to this consciousness of a character
that you're creating do you find is
there barrier there is there kind of is
there a gulf that you experience or is
it just a matter of trying to relate to
just the practical I have this set of
experience is directly applicable to a
fictionalized male character and and is
that a is that a responsibility that you
feel remains for you or do you like you
see that they're challenging society I
feel no abstract responsibility you know
to count votes about how many credible
female characters the the I think that
I'm the product of Society which
obviously in which women are not given
the opportunity to develop as fully in
ways that are accessible to my
understanding but I try to the character
of Alma Garrett in Deadwood is a pretty
complicated figure the character of
calamity jane i believe is is pretty
complicated the character of Stubbs
becomes pretty complicated she was a
real figure too but no that's Trixie
yeah Trixie is pretty complicated too
but but the the fact is that there are
stunted effects in the women characters
in the worlds that I write about because
women are encouraged to believe that
they exist as adjuncts of the male will
or the male fantasy and you know it
wasn't just the prostitutes in Deadwood
but in in in society times around this
time women were imprisoned in a
different way they were imprisoned and
bustles and all kinds of strand and
treated with this
elevated rhetoric which in fact was
incapacitating to them they were
idealized you know Alice James diary is
a wonderful document in that regard she
found that only once she had begun to
die of a tumor that she discovered her
voice Henry and William James younger
sister hysteria literally is derived
from of the womb that that it is so that
when a woman began to feel as if she
were thwarted she was diagnosed as being
hysterical which is simply to say her
womb was driving her and they would give
her opium which was the treatment the
accepted treatment for hysteria so you
know I I I take the characters as I find
them I'm sure that now Alma as it turns
out becomes a writer in the fourth
season and she's encouraged by another
character who who actually came to the
camp in the first year but for whom I I
would not settle until we got the right
actor it was a theatrical producer named
jack langrishe she was played by Brian
Cox who appears in the third season and
langrishe encouraged Alma to resume what
she had lied about is her original
impulse coming out there which was to be
a writer and there's a good deal of sort
of Willa Cather's experienced that I
hope to mine for the character of Alma
Garrett but so I don't know if I'd
answered your question it's it's always
an admixture of the limitations of the
artists own imagination and sort of the
psychic cards that he's been tailed and
the prevailing conventions at the time I
wish I wish I had one answer for it
don't try to do better that was mine
they aren't they are very masculine
worlds and they are yeah and this world
this is a Victorian one in which in
which women are not
equal to men I want to thank David Milch
very much for this and let me say from
my heart please engage in the things
we're talking about don't give up on
mass culture contribute to it break your
heart in trying to make it better
instead of standing outside our species
is in a fight for its life and you know
nobody says that the decision is is
gonna go one way or another
so put your bodies up and put your
spirits up and get in touch with me if
you you know I'm very open to that kind
of stuff and anything that you want to
do you know just feel as if this stuff
about that we don't have the vote
anymore
we're just not voting in the right
election you know and you can all you
all come and vote with me okay
you
you